1848, and the Austrian Empire
is having some trouble.
This trouble occured on March the 13th in Vienna,
When a crowd, mostly made up of students, demanded more rights,
And the government obliged.
By shooting them.
Which led to riots. This riot was a part of larger trend of revolutions which swept across Europe in 1848
To oversimplify, they were largely concerned
with improving the working lifes of the peasantry,
Increacsing democratic representation,
and in many cases wanted to form states along national, ethnic and linguistic lines.
This was bad news for the Austrian Empire,
since it was very diverse. It included
many ethnic groups such as Germans, Hungarias, Czecks, Slovaks, Ukrainians
Called Ruthenians at the times
Poles (known as Galicians), Croats
Serbs, Italians, Romanians and many, many others.
Some of these people wanted better representation, and others preferred outright independence.
The events in 1848 spread outside of Vienna quickly, and March 15th
In the city of Pest, revolutionaries demanded extra rights and soon after
declared Hungarian independence.But Ferdinand would still be their king
The central government struggled to respond
affectively. and in Italy the Austrian army withdrew from
from most of the revolting Italian states. this left them wide open
for invasion.